cela fait une semaine que l'opération
cuisines en fête est lancé al'approche
de noël et du nouvel an le chef étoilé
laurent trochain avec l'aide de la
députée aurore bergé à créer une
cartographie du territoire sud yvelines
qui recense les restaurateurs et
traiteurs
objectif jouer collectif pour se faire
connaître dans cette période de crise
sanitaire
c'est de nous donner un miroir et de
nous faire connaître dans notre activité
de traiteur qui est nouvelle et qui
n'est pas notre activité d'ailleurs mais
on s'en sort on s'en sort plutôt très
bien parce que on a une clientèle qui
qui est magnifique et reconnaissante et
qui nous soutient depuis le début des
deux premiers confinement donc les
initiatives et ben depuis mars dernier
beaucoup de professionnels ont développé
la vente à emporter et la livraison avec
cette cartographie réalisée
gracieusement par l'association la
fabrique de rambouillet les restaurants
peuvent donc développer leurs réseaux de
communication
les gens vont dessus et après ils
peuvent choisir par rapport à une carte
google maps le restaurant qui juge
qu'ils veulent ils cliquent dessus et
après ça on voit tous les liens de
chaque restaurant dessus vous ce
regroupement fait que ça ça redonne le
moral en ce sens pas tout seul on se
sent tous s'entraider et ça ça ça fait
beaucoup
ça nous donne du peps pour repartir à
essayer de retrouver des solutions s'il
y en a le site cuisines en fête regroupe
donc 21 restaurants ainsi que trois
traiteurs et deux autres professionnels
de la restauration de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
un moyen de continuer à travailler en
cette période compliquée